if i owned a business i wouldn't be  impressed i would be pissed off i'd say  go apply online and slam the door in  your face good thing you don't own a  business you know what i've noticed is  people with that mindset usually don't  do well in business because business is  about risk and a lot of business owners  appreciate people that take risks i took  a risk i knew people would slam the door  in my face my thought was worst case  scenario they tell me no best case  scenario i have a job what do i have to  loot apply online like thousands of  other people or do something different  i'm not even saying this is the best way  to do it but what i'm saying is you  shouldn't be afraid to try things that  might not work it only takes something  working once for it to pay off